je vous entraîne aujourd'hui dans un
musée assez extraordinaire puisqu'il
mêle à la fois l'histoire et la création
contemporaine c'est le musée de la toile
de jouy à jouy en josas je vais
rejoindre sa directrice et conservatrice
est clairement de bouteilles bonjour un
objet de la conservatrice et la
directrice du musée la toile de huy à
jouy en josas un mot peut-être que je
prenne ou esclarmonde avec la très joli
prénom original et qui vient des katas
en fait des albigeois nom est originaire
la famille du sud-ouest voilà alors on
va peut-être commencer va parler de ce
lieu où se trouve ce musée depuis 97 je
crois 91 entendre il avait été créé le
musée en 77 par le maire jacques oudin à
l'époque dans le château montebello sur
la ghréline et
lieux s'est avéré trop petit et madame
le sein le maire suivant a fait
déménager le musée dans ce château de
l'églantine qui appartenait au maréchal
quand robert et a fait construire une
extension moderne pour pouvoir
l'utiliser en musée oui donc c'est un
lieu historique
c'est un lieu historique mais qui n'a
pas non plus de lien avec oberkampf
puisque ce bâtiment sis date de la fin
du 19e et bien après la période
d'oberkampf d'accord alors la toile de
jouy
qu'est ce que c'est parce que alors on a
une image tous en tête à ça fait partie
de notre imaginaire collectif la toile
de jouy si on en parle aux gens y voient
des bergères des moutons dans un paysage
idyllique et en général en rouge
en fait c'était beaucoup plus que ça
puisque oberkampf faisait à la fois des
perses comme les murs qui nous entourent
c'est à dire des grandes fleurs colorées
voilà sur des tissus pour l'ameublement
mais il faisait aussi des tissus pour la
robe comme on disait à l'époque c'est à
dire des tissus pour les habits d'accord
et là une filet de tous y compris des
motifs géométriques et on pense qu'il y
avait plus de 30 minutes motifs qui ont
été produits à jouer s'est produit ici
c'était la manufacture s'étendait à peu
près sur 14 hectares jusqu'aux centres
de jouer et quand elle a fermé en 1843
elle a été vendue aux enchères des
membres est détruite et il reste plus
rien que la mairie actuelle qui était
une aile de la maison d'aubert quand
aujourd'hui alors où est ce que ce
produit la toile aujourd'hui en fait
tout ça est passé plus ou moins dans le
patrimoine commun et les éditeurs de
textile que ça soit mft à pierre frey
burget
et tous les grands éditeurs de taksim
d'ameublement reprennent des motifs de
toiles de jouer alors c'est quoi le
tissu de la toile de jouy c'est du coton
c'est du costaud 1 ce qui est une grande
innovation au xviiie siècle puisque en
fait nos contre elle ne produisait pas
de coton jusqu'au 18e on importe tout ça
de l'inde et oberkampf lui-même achète
ses toiles blanches aux ventes des
compagnies des indes à la fois en
angleterre ou à lorient alors qu'ils qui
est au bord quand on connaît la station
métro et la rue c'est un immigrés
d'origine germanique l arrondi
l'allemagne évidemment en 1738 continuer
la halle même c'est un concept qui
n'existe pas voilà ce n'est dans le sud
de l'allemagne actuelle en 1738 dans une
famille de teinturier
son père aussi produit des toiles
imprimées et son père le fait formé dans
des bonnes manufacture de l'époque en
alsace ou à bâle en suisse et ils
acquièrent en fait toutes les
connaissances qu'ils servent pour
imprimer une toile
il s'est dessinée il s'est gravé ses
planches il sait choisir ses toiles il
et coloriste donc si c'était toute la
chaîne voilà il a libéré il importe les
tôles d'un de vapeur est en fait ils
arrivent en france parce qu'on va le
chercher parce qu'en france on a eu un
truc encore intelligence et qu'on a eu
une prohibition sur la production de
toiles imprimées qui a duré presque 70
ans
et pourquoi parce que les soyeux
lyonnais et les fabricants de dram enfin
voilà de normandie avait peur de ses
toiles de marché oui et c'est interdit
des ports heurter les produire de les
importer évidemment ça n'a pas marché la
mode a continué à les faire rentrer en
contrebande mais on a perdu tout le
savoir faire et quand la prohibition
élevés dans les années 1750 9 à peu près
on a plus de d'ouvriers qualifiés donc
des gens vont chercher ces ouvriers dont
oberkampf quand ça arrive en 1758 en
semences et qui va vivre en france
tout ça j alors il est immigré et en
plus si les protestants donc c'est il a
pas du tout tout les tous les atouts de
son côté
mais il comprend assez vite qu'en fait
il faut se mettre à son compte
parce qu'au départ il est simple ouvrier
et il réussit à passer un ouvrier qui
travaille alors dans l'enclos de
l'arsenal à paris pour un dénommé cottin
et il fait venir son frère aussi et ils
trouvent des investisseurs dans
l'entourage du roi et parce qu'il faut
en fait c'est une industrie assez
capitalistique pour acheter les toiles
blanches fois agilité ce qu'ils
appellent les drogues qui sont les
produits chimiques pour faire les
couleurs etc
donc ils trouvent des investisseurs qui
s'associe à lui et il monte sa première
entreprise en 1760 à jouer dans une
toute petite maison qui est actuellement
l'école de musique de jouy qu'on peut
voir
oui aujourd'hui parce que c'est là coco
produits l'homme non parce qu'en fait
ils vont s'éloigner de paris et des
problèmes des émeutes enfin des rock
stars
voilà il lui faut de l'eau et donc il
suit la vallée de la bièvre et là il est
à trois kilomètres de son marché qui est
versailles puisqu'au départ en fait les
toiles de jouy sont très chers et c'est
la cour qu'il est les machettes et il
pas l'adversaire usa et je voulais à
l'époque c'est quoi ça dix vit dans un
petit village d'agriculteurs enfin c'est
vraiment la campagne profonde
il n'y a rien du tout d'ailleurs il est
mal vu au début quand il arrive et puis
le seigneur du point est voit pas trop
bien le fait qu'ils s'installent comme
ça et puis petit à petit en fait il va
acheter des terres et des terres et des
terres et il a besoin de prairies aussi
pour étendre ses toiles pour les faire
blanchir doit plus dire coluche il va
finir très riche il va être alors ils
traversent tous les régimes
il est anobli il commence sous louis 15
il est anobli sous l'ancien régime il
réglé cet été la révolution jour comme
sur 215 voix là et il va être anobli
naturalisé français
premier maire de jouy sous la révolution
distingué par le comité de salut public
pour un service rendu à la nation et
décoré par napoléon lui-même qui vient à
jouer et qui lui accroche sa propre
légion d'honneur
c'est un opportuniste où il a des
convictions politiques
alors je pense que d'après enfin avec
son passé ouvrier il a quand même des
convictions ses enfants s'appelle emilie
deux de ses enfants qui l'a lu rousseau
voilà après c'est pas un révolutionnaire
mais il fait toujours beaucoup de choses
pour ses ouvriers pour améliorer leurs
conditions pour essayer qui deviennent
propriétaires qu'ils s'instruisent qu'il
vous quel côté protestant aussi qui fait
qu'il faut savoir lire
donc voilà alors voilà voilà pour
l'histoire le le musée donc depuis
quatre ans 11 vous l'avais dit dans nos
cellules qu'est-ce qu'est ce qu'on voit
dans ce musée
alors on voit une collection permanente
oui oui oui mais qu'on est obligé de
faire tourner puisque les textiles on
peut pas les laisser exposés trop
longtemps oui ça se fait tout seul c'est
fragile donc on a une exposition
permanente qui montre les productions de
la manufacture et des manufactures
concurrentes parce qu'en fait il n'était
pas tout seul même à l'époque il y avait
d'autres manufactures qui produisait ce
qu'on appellerait aujourd'hui de la
toile de jouer qu'on montre tout ça et
puis une évocation de son intérieur où
nous sommes las du salon dans lequel il
habitait en soit là de la manufacture et
de la technique d'impression sur étoffes
qui étaient impliqués à l'époque donc ça
on peut tout le vois bordeaux c'est que
même si c'est le bouge aussi
et puis il ya des expositions y en a une
actuellement oui il ya des expositions
temporaires dans la salle justement qui
l extension contemporaine
en ce moment nous avons l'exposition art
texture à leur texture c'est un concours
de créations textiles contemporaines qui
organisé par l'association france
patchwork tous les deux ans et les
projets retenus ton plat il y en a une
trentaine il y en a plus de 100
concurrents qui viennent de toute
l'europe et même d'asie
oui mais on a des oeuvres d'artistes
japonais est une oeuvre monumentale
d'une artiste québécoise
voilà qui est invité d'honneur qui
s'appelle qui s'appelle carole si marc
laflamme et alors c'est ça la cdc
tassetto d'envoi parce que ces décès des
créations très très contemporain d'art
contemporain mais mais ça se rapporte
aussi à oberkampf à ce qu'il a toujours
essayé d'être à la pointe des
innovations techniques technologiques
mais aussi du goût des changements de
de la mode donc on est tout à fait dans
dans le film enfin c'est intéressant
pour un petit des artistes contemporains
qui s'intéressent à cette matière oui
oui et même en fait beaucoup d'artistes
contemporains s'intéresse à la toile de
jouy à ce que ça véhicule comme idée il
ya il y à un artiste florent boutique
qui avaient été exposées ici qui a fait
des portraits sur un fond de toile de
jouy et puis on a une classe aussi de
projet artistique et culturel de l'école
de jouer qui travaille avec un jeune
artiste en ce moment jérémy lobée qui
est en résidence au centquatre sur la
toile de jouy
donc il ya souvent des artistes
contemporains qui s'en inspirent ou
qu'ils utilisent et puis y aura 2015
alors ce sera des 200 ans de l'homme
borders burke ans notamment
donc il va y avoir beaucoup de choses
nikos 2015 il faut qu'on fasse vraiment
de gros événements on est déjà partie
des commémorations nationales qui chaque
année la nation célèbre les
anniversaires
on va faire une grosse exposition sur
toute l'oeuvre et la vie d'oberkampf on
va essayer d'avoir alors là je vais à
kyoto bientôt kyoto costume institute
qui possède la robe de cours dans
laquelle madame oberkampf a été présenté
à la cour versailles pour que se trouve
là parce que c'est eux qui l'ont acheté
c'était par we salute pressé en vente en
2004 en a pas eu les moyens nous de
lâche t elle est là bas et on espère
aussi faire tout un cycle de conférences
sur toute l'année et un colloque dont on
espère qu'ils soient hébergés à hec
autour de justement cette révolution
industrielle dont oberkampf est l'un des
exemples
oui vous pouvez aussi bénéficier de
du fait que jouer bref la chaussée c'est
une ville qui est en plein moment quel
âge au musée c'est en musique schiphol
c'est un musée municipal mais oui c'est
vrai que alors on parle de juillet h
essais mais ça reste une commune à ces
petites îles à 8000 habitants dont 500
c'est vrai que c'est un assez gros poids
financier pour la commune et c'est bien
que les maires successifs et il réussit
à préserver et à promouvoir ce
patrimoine vous même comme vous comment
vous est venu à vous intéresser à la
toile de jouy alors moi au départ j'ai
fait une école de commerce pas à chasser
une option mais j'étais toujours
intéressé par l'art et j'ai fait ensuite
l'école du lourd une cour de
conservateurs j'ai commencé par
construire un musée d'archéologie en
picardie et puis quand j'ai vu que le
poste ici a été libre j'ai toujours
adoré les textiles dont je me suis dit
ben voilà c'est c'est une chance
postulons à jouer on verra bien et vous
que vous êtes passionné pour probable
pour moi record pour l'histoire et pour
les créations contemporaines puisque
c'est ça qui est très intéressant dans
ce musée c'est qu'à la foire peut voir
l'histoire de la toile de jouy mais on
peut voir aussi des créations d'artistes
contemporains le musée est ouvert
alors il est ouvert tous les jours du
mardi au dimanche à partir de 11h 12h à
18h et on est fermé je crois pour noël
ou le nouvel emprunt de joueurs toujours
par toute façon c'est facile à trouver
un site internet
on a aussi une application pour
tablettes et smartphones qui a été payé
par les amis du musée
donc ça vaut tout on peut la télécharger
allegra tuit pour une première approche
donc on va vous dire quelque chose voilà
renseignez vous et puis venaient dans ce
musée qui est à la fois un lieu sublime
historique est à la fois au pouvoir des
choses tout à fait étonnante merci
infiniment merci à vous